Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Muriel de Meo
L'anno scorso, l'amministrazione comunale
ha proposto alla Scuola Media "Parini"
di eleggere il Consiglio
Comunale dei Ragazzi.
Le elezioni sono state fatte così:
ogni classe ha eletto
quattro rappresentanti,
due ragazze e due ragazzi,
una specie di primarie.
I rappresentanti delle classi, riuniti,
hanno formato le liste:
erano tre, io facevo parte
di una di queste.
Ogni lista ha redatto il suo programma,
ha scelto il proprio simbolo
e il candidato sindaco.
I programmi sono stati esposti
a tutti gli studenti
riuniti nell'Aula Magna.
Tutti gli alunni
della scuola hanno votato,
è stata votata la mia lista
e io sono stato eletto Sindaco.
Come Sindaco, rappresento -
(Applausi)
Come Sindaco, rappresento
tutti i miei compagni.
Anche le mie parole di oggi
esprimono le opinioni dei miei compagni.
Andrea, di Via Volta;
Josè Miguel, nato a L'Avana,
che abita in Via Cadorna;
Francesco, di Via Lambertenghi;
David, che viene dal Brasile
e abita in Via Milano;
Pietro, di Via Ferrari;
Stefan viene dalla Romania
ed abita a Camerlata;
Andrea di Via XX Settembre;
Terry, nato in Ecuador, vive in Via Benzi;
Silvia di Via Valleggio;
Luca di Via Rezzonico.
Non posso elencarli tutti, ma era per dire
che abbiamo parlato insieme
di quello che vi dirò.
Noi viviamo la città in due modi:
muovendoci e stando fermi.
Muovendoci.
La maggior parte delle volte,
noi guardiamo la città percorrendola.
Andare per strada a Como
non è proprio piacevole;
è vero che ci sono edifici
e palazzi belli,
restiamo sempre incuriositi da tante cose;
ma i percorsi non sono continui,
non scorrono bene,
sono sempre interrotti, a brevi pezzetti.
Uno non riesce a prendere
un bel camminare tranquillo, continuo,
magari a guardare un po' per aria:
sembra che ci siano sempre interruzioni,
manca la continuità.
Bisognerebbe curare i percorsi dei pedoni,
che dovrebbero proseguire
anche fuori dal centro storico.
Invece è tutto spezzettato
dalle attese ai semafori,
dalle macchine che ripartono e accelerano,
dai pavimenti che cambiano.
Un bel tratto di percorso
pedonale continuo
è il marciapiede vicino ai parcheggi
dell'area che, mi hanno detto,
era dello zoo, in Via Sant'Elia.
Ecco, lì è bello camminare tra gli alberi,
e protetti da una siepe bassa.
Anche il parco vicino
è molto bello e tenuto bene.
Quando un parco è tenuto bene,
nessuno lo rovina;
e forse è per questo
che molti parchi tenuti male
sono anche rovinati da vandalismi.
Vorremmo una città
dove le piste ciclabili
ci fossero davvero,
non quei piccoli tratti
come in Via Cadorna
davanti al Conservatorio,
dove c'è un tratto ciclabile
lungo 25 metri
che non si sa da dove venga e dove vada.
(Risate)
Le piste ciclabili sono belle
quando scorrono sicure, continue,
e non sono delle trappole
dove ci vuole più attenzione
a restare indenni che a pedalare.
Sulle ciclabili dovrebbero
poter andare anche i bambini,
senza la sorveglianza dei genitori.
Un bel tratto di ciclabile potrebbe essere
quello di Viale Cavallotti e Viale Varese.
Tra le bici e le automobili
c'è un filare di alberi,
che toglie un po' di smog
e di confusione della strada.
Forse sarebbe meglio
che le piste ciclabili
non ci fossero affatto,
ma che ovunque si potesse andare in bici.
Le auto dovrebbero avere
un loro itinerario separato,
separato da un po' di alberi per esempio.
Vorrei salire sulla montagna
della Spina Verde, o di Brunate,
direttamente dalla città,
passeggiando con i miei amici
per guardare con loro il bosco,
incontrare un cinghiale,
guardare i tetti dall'alto.
Vorrei salire sulle mura
e fare il giro scendendo al lago.
Come una volta, quando il percorso
era in mezzo agli alberi.
L'ho visto su un libro
che racconta com'era la città
quando hanno costruito il Teatro Sociale.
Anche due e o tre volte di seguito,
così potrei vedere la città da sopra.
Stando fermi.
Gli spazi a Como, per la gente
e soprattutto per i ragazzi, sono pochi -
voglio dire, gli spazi dove vien voglia
di fermarsi, di parlare, di stare.
Anche nel centro storico
le strade si restringono
per far posto ai tavolini dei bar;
uno per fermarsi un attimo
dovrebbe sedersi a un bar
e ordinare qualcosa,
così noi ragazzi siamo esclusi.
Siamo esclusi, anche,
da tutte queste vetrine,
una dietro l'altra
per chilometri di strade pedonali.
Noi ragazzi le vetrine le guardiamo poco,
fino a che non siamo assorbiti
dai gusti dei grandi.
Ci vorrebbero degli spazi
dove ci sono dei muretti,
delle panche per sedersi,
magari in posizioni dove è bello guardare
quello che succede intorno.
Piazza del Duomo è bella,
anche la piazza che sta dietro;
ma uno dove si mette, dove si siede?
Quando mettono le casette di legno
per Natale, sotto il Broletto,
e si forma un piano unico,
sembra che stare sotto il portico
sia molto più bello,
un posto bello per fermarsi;
ma normalmente, quando c'è quel buco
e bisogna scendere, nessuno ci va.
Vorrei una città dove ci siano
molti più parchi e giardini,
dove si possano guardare le piante,
perché lì ci si sente più liberi,
e si possa anche correre.
C'è uno spazio verde,
vicino alla Chiesa di S. Antonio
in Via Rezzonico;
perché nessuno la usa?
Questa parte della città
è quasi senza un minimo di verde,
o di un posto per sedersi.
Si potrebbe fare una piccola area
per stare, o un parco.
Anche la chiesa è un peccato
che sia un negozio,
bisognerebbe che fosse
almeno un luogo pubblico,
per trovarsi e fare insieme qualcosa.
Vorrei una città con più portici,
dove poter stare anche quando piove.
Qui a Como piove molto,
e ci vogliono posti al coperto.
Ho visto delle stampe antiche
di Piazza Cavour:
era tutta circondata da portici.
È vero, ci sono anche adesso,
sotto l'Hotel Barchetta
e nell'edificio dopo,
i portici di Via Pinio<
ma tra vetrine e negozi
non si può proprio stare.
Vorrei poter toccare l'acqua del lago,
e non solo guardarla dal parapetto.
Vorrei che ci fossero dei battelli fermi,
per poterci salire
e vedere come funzionano.
Uno spazio verde, tutto da recuperare,
l'ho notato dal treno:
è il vecchio scalo ferroviario
che si trova sopra la Via Regina,
tra Sant'Abbondio
e la stazione di Como S. Giovanni.
Serviva una volta,
ma oggi è abbandonato
e invaso da piante infestanti.
È un percorso lunghissimo,
sono più di 800 metri di lunghezza.
Ci sono ancora i binari,
ma sono quasi sepolti dalla vegetazione.
Siamo stati a vedere questo posto,
faceva anche un po' paura,
perché si capiva
che negli edifici abbandonati
ci vive della gente
clandestina, in difficoltà.
Sarebbe bellissimo mettere a posto
questo grande spazio inutilizzato.
Propongo di farci,
innanzitutto, delle grandi pareti,
sulle quali tutti quelli
che hanno voglia di fare i graffitari
possono disegnare a loro piacimento.
I loro dipinti saranno visti bene
da chi passa con il treno,
venendo anche da lontano o dall'estero.
Poi farei un grande parco delle ferrovie,
esponendo sui binari morti
locomotive e vagoni,
facendo vedere, anche,
come sono fatti nei meccanismi.
Sarebbe bello poterci girare,
e capire come davvero funzionano i treni.
Ruote, carrelli, freni,
sospensioni, respingenti, pantografi:
tutto circondato dal verde,
un parco appunto.
Naturalmente, troviamo anche una casa vera
per la gente che, adesso,
dorme lì clandestinamente.
Non credo che io e i miei amici
vogliamo cose speciali e straordinarie.
Per le cose strane
ci sono già Gardaland,
Disneyland, gli Aquapark,
le piste da sci, i villaggi turistici,
dove tutti prima o poi finiamo per andare.
Non ci bastano giochi per bambini
dietro a recinti,
con scivoli, castelli, arrampicate,
che stancano dopo cinque minuti;
divieto di utilizzare i giochi
divisi per età.
Non vogliamo stare isolati
dalla città vera.
Quello che può interessare noi
deve piacere anche agli adulti,
che devono poter correre
anche loro sulle mura,
come i bambini più piccoli.
Como è una città bella,
che dovrebbe essere solo trattata meglio.
Le cose che ci sono
vanno messe a posto e tenute bene.
Bisogna riuscire a capire
come farle funzionare,
stando bene a tutti.
La città che vorrei esiste già.
Non bisogna inventarne una nuova,
bisogna solo ravvivarla.
Guardandola con gli occhi nuovi,
anche con gli occhi di noi ragazzi.
(Applausi)